today on the matt walsh show another pop
star comes out as non-binary and demands
that we use they them pronouns lots of
people even conservatives seem perfectly
willing to go along with the preferred
pronoun thing these days but i'll
explain why we shouldn't and why the
issue does in fact matter also five
headlines including blm finds its newest
martyr a ten-year-old boy speaks out
eloquently against the masking insanity
and airlines
will start weighing passengers before
boarding that'll be interesting in our
daily cancellation i have the distinct
honor and privilege of canceling chris
cuomo again and i'll explain why all of
that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
lately the pop singer demi lovato has
been on quite the journey for publicity
sorry uh i mean self-discovery after
coming out as queer her word uh and then
pansexual she's now decided that she's
actually no she's not that she's
non-binary and she'll be using they them
pronouns from this point forward or at
least until a trendier option presents
itself the mainstream media has been all
over this breaking news and the
headlines have been as weird and
headache-inducing as you might expect in
an article
a cbs news article confusingly titled
demi lovato announces they are
non-binary and changing their pronouns
they reported the following this is a
reading from the article now it says
see if you can follow along it says
singer demi lovato has announced that
they are non-binary and are changing
their pronouns to they them they said
that the revelation followed a quote a
lot of healing and self-reflective work
in a twitter video early wednesday
morning introducing their new podcast
the pop singer says they don't identify
as male or female on their podcast
lovato said that quote it would mean the
world if people used their correct
pronouns but they will be accepting if
people accidentally use she her pronouns
and they just want
want them to be making the effort i i ca
i can't even follow and i'm reading it
now look if you went into a coma
sometime in the year 2015 or so it had
just now woken up the preceding
paragraph would be rather bewildering
you would be forgiven for assuming that
demi lovato is the name for some sort of
group or collective
if you heard someone say
i saw demi lovato in concert and they
were really good you would immediately
conclude that demi lovato is an entire
band not one single person
this conclusion would be justified as it
would be based on the rules of the
english language
little would you know that demi lovato
is a single individual
and also by the way that she's not that
good in concert
for the record here is lovato herself
um or themselves explaining why she
slash they has slash have made this
change
this is 4d with demi lovato
[Music]
living in the fourth dimension means
existing consciously and both time and
space but for me it means having
conversations that transcend the typical
discourse i want to take this moment to
share something very personal with you
over the past year and a half i've been
doing some healing and self-reflective
work and through this work i've had the
revelation that i identify as non-binary
with that said i'll officially be
changing my pronouns to they them i feel
that this best represents the fluidity i
feel in my gender expression and allows
me to feel most authentic and true to
the person i both know i am and still am
discovering
in this first episode i'm excited to
share with you
what this means to me and what it may
look like for other people
i want to make it clear that i'm still
learning and coming into myself and i
don't claim to be an expert or a
spokesperson
now it's helpful that she began her
explanation the way that she did so that
it would be painfully clear that the
whole thing is nothing but ridiculous
psychobabble
living in the fourth dimension means
existing consciously in both time and
space what is that supposed to mean
what other option do we have but to
exist consciously in both time and space
can i exist consciously in space but not
time
can i exist in neither space nor time
can i be
a spaceless timeless shapeless vapor
floating aimlessly through an eternal
abyss
i suppose i suppose it's only a matter
of time before demi lovato assumes that
identity for herself or for themselves
as i've often argued the proliferation
of these ambiguous alternative
identities is really when it comes down
to it a proliferation of narcissism
lovato can't explain what identifying as
non-binary means
she can't tell us how she arrived at
this conclusion about herself none of
this can be made coherent
because it doesn't really mean anything
what she's trying to say actually is
that is that she is more complex and
interesting than the average person
she's not
she's not sure who she is exactly but
she's sure that whoever she is
she must not be what everyone else is
her identity transcends all labels
except the 15 different labels she's
given herself over the last six months
but look that's all her concern
she's free to play whatever word game
she wants to play she's free to make
whatever claims about herself that she
wants to make the problem
is that we are not simply asked to leave
people alone and let them live how they
want and identify how they want
that used to be
the request or what seemed like a
request at the time to some people
just let let people live how they want
let them be right
it's not the case anymore
it's now demanded that we participate
that we take active roles in affirming
and supporting the self-identity of
strangers
i'm fine with leaving people alone if i
heard through the grapevine that my
neighbor three doors down identifies as
a cantaloupe i'm not gonna go knock on
his door and scream at him to leave his
cantaloupe fantasies behind you're not a
cantaloupe damn it
i wouldn't do that
but if i'm told that i must in any way
affirm or reinforce the cantaloupe
delusion
then i will have to respectfully decline
he can think whatever he wants but he
can't force me to think it or to pretend
that i think it
i'm not intruding on his life when i
protest or resist
such an imposition i am stopping him
from intruding on mine
he might live in a world where men can
be cantaloupe cantaloupes but but i
don't
i live in the real world
and i'd like to remain here
that's my lifestyle choice and i will
insist that it be respected
and so it goes with pronouns
a pronoun
is a grammatical construct it's part of
language
it's not a pet that you can own it's not
your pet goldfish
it's not a fashion accessory that you
can wear
you don't get your own pronouns
just as you don't get your own
prepositions or your own adverbs
i suppose a man might have a special
affinity for the preposition on
but that doesn't change what the word on
means
if he is not sitting on a chair but says
that he identifies as sitting on it
because his preferred preposition is on
that wouldn't change his actual physical
relationship to the chair in real life
and by demanding that we all pretend
that the word on means off and off means
on he is the one trying to impose
himself on us
or off of us as the case may be for the
sake of preserving language as a tool
for conveying meaning which is the whole
reason why language exists in the first
place we would have to resist
those efforts
in the english language the word he
is a pronoun that refers to males
she refers to females
that's how it works in english
they refers either to multiple people or
to an unknown person it would be
perfectly valid to say for example look
someone left their wallet here i hope
they come back for it
or i hope they don't come back for it if
you're a less honest person
but it would not be valid to say look my
friend george left their wallet here i
hope they come back for it
that doesn't make any sense
because i know who george is i know that
he's male
i know that he's only one person not
siamese twins
the word they in that context would be
deceptive and confusing
and it would fail to convey meaning
which again is the entire point of
language
in fact they in that context let's say
that my friend george
is non-binary whatever exactly that
means
and i use the word they
what am i actually saying what what
meaning am i conveying
because he's a male and he's only one
person
so they in that context is referring to
his perception of himself
it's referring to his feelings about
himself
but that is not what pronouns are
supposed to do
pronouns are not concerned with your
self-perception or how you feel
we we have language we have words that
can
talk about that
but when i'm but when we are using
pronouns
it is a reference to who an individual
actually is
not how they see themselves
not how they feel that's irrelevant to
the pronoun
now it's true that language evolves over
time but
the preferred pronoun phenomenon is is
not an example of linguistic evolution
let's be very clear about this
the people pushing this change are
indeed pushing it
they're not just observing that it's
already happened
it is a top-down change it's not an
organic development
the cultural powers that be have decided
that certain words should no longer mean
what they have always meant though they
can't be bothered to tell us what those
words should mean now instead
they are by forcing coercion attempting
to remove the meaning from words without
replacing the words with new meaning
see language develops naturally over
time in order to better convey meaning
in our case
language is being manipulated
intentionally in order to make it less
meaningful
that is a very very different thing
why does all this matter i would hope
it'd be obvious by now
language matters
we cannot have a human society without
it
truth matters
we cannot have a society worth living in
without it we are witnessing an attack
on both language and truth and thus on
society
and that matters
and it only requires a little backbone
to oppose it
now let's get to our five headlines
you know we talk a lot about cancel
culture on this show and over the daily
wire in general we know that uh the the
primary agents of cancel culture the
people that have the power to really
cancel you uh that's that would be big
tech of course
and how do we how do we uh how do we
stop big tech from doing that to us well
that's what you need expressvpn for
instead of letting big tech cancel your
right to free speech how about canceling
their access to your private data that's
why i use expressvpn and you should too
have you ever wondered how huge tech
sites make their money when they're
actually supposedly free to use well
they do it by tracking your searches
your video history everything you click
on and then selling your valuable data
to third parties when you use expressvpn
your device's ip address gets masked and
this helped that that's one form of
masking that i support by the way this
helps um make your online activity
anonymous and that'll make it much more
difficult to trace and sell to
advertisers expressvpn also encrypts 100
of your network data to protect you from
cyber criminals and hackers uh so you've
just got to try you've got to use
expressvpn and protect yourself protect
your data it's time to say no to
censorship and take back your online
privacy at expressvpn.comwalsh
visit my link and you'll get an extra
three months of expressvpn service for
free that's
expressvpn.comwalls to protect your data
today
i want to play this first this is not a
headline really but um i got to play it
anyway the ch the giant toad bill de
blasio
um every other day he's got a press
conference embarrassing himself
and i didn't give him credit
embarrassing himself in new and
unexpected and interesting ways
so um here's the if you're not if you're
only listening you're gonna have to go
later watch the video on youtube or on
dailywire.com cause you got you gotta
you gotta see the visual to get the full
effect but let's uh let's play here's
bill de blasio yesterday at his daily
press briefing
but the biggest victory
for the nets
is yet to come
the nets are stepping up
for brooklyn for the whole city of new
york the nets are now going to be
joining the battle against covid
with a mobile vaccination site right
outside barclays center
he's uh so he's wearing
the problem there is not so much what
he's saying it's it's what he's wearing
he's wearing a ball cap
and a jersey and uh he looks like like
benjamin button there or something
he looks like a school guidance
counselor at a pep rally
now you know what he looks like he looks
like a what what what do i look for he
looks for like a massive tool is what he
looks like i can just imagine this guy
in that outfit
trying to fit in and coming up to you
like hey bro did you catch the sports
competition yesterday evening
man our home team really
really scored some points it was wild
i've never seen a team make so many
touchdowns in one evening in one inning
incredible
that's and this guy was
every time i see him like what
if you're
and i know to try to get into the to the
mindset of a voter in new york city it's
it's a fruitless task and rather
disturbing to a disturbing journey into
that mind but but what about him
when he's running for mayor what about
him
made you say oh i gotta i need that guy
in charge of this city that i'm living
in
i really wanna i want someone who lives
in new york city to explain that to me
if you live in new york city and you
voted for bill de blasio i
and i and i mean this sincerely
i'm not trying to attack you
even though you're an idiot i i really
want to know why what what about him did
you like
maybe maybe it's me maybe i'm not seeing
it
maybe it's not him it's me i don't know
all right let's move on to our first
real headline here the latest blm martyr
is andrew brown he was a man in north
carolina who was shot and killed by the
cops
a month or so ago
while they were trying to arrest him
he was a drug dealer he had
as always with these things he had a
long rap she had arrested dozens of
times already he was convicted of
resisting arrest also on like four other
occasions
charged with resisting arrest on 10
other occasions
he was uh shot
the media says
while unarmed and that's been the report
that's what we've been hearing from the
media
for weeks now that there's another
unarmed black man that was uh shot by
the cops but that's not actually true
the local prosecutor held a press
conference yesterday and announced that
the cops in the case will not face
charges and that has a lot to do with
the fact that brown
was not really unarmed
he was in a vehicle and he was using it
as a weapon
so that that might technically
count in the way that they
figure out these statistics
that might technically count as quote
unquote unarmed
but in reality he's not unarmed he's got
a weapon
um which is this large
metal contraption that he is
sitting in and steering in the direction
of of officers now i would play the body
cam footage for you and i would like to
play it but uh it was released yesterday
as well
during that press conference with the
prosecutor but if i do that i've learned
that youtube will use it as an excuse to
lock the showdown and put the the uh put
the
age lock on it or whatever so i'm not
gonna do that you can go and watch it
online easily if you want but you can
clearly see the guy
in the body cam footage
when the cops show up whole bunch of
them
there's a whole bunch of them and they
had their guns drawn because this is a
known drug dealer with a long rap sheet
and so they came in you know ready and
also someone who's who has resisted
arrest many times in the past so they're
prepared for that um they come in
they're screaming at him to surrender
instead he gets into his car and drives
it right at a group of officers that's
when they opened fire and he was killed
in the process now andrew brown's family
though is of course asking the feds to
get involved
which i would not be surprised at all if
they do
uh this is from cnn that says the
attorneys for the family of andrew brown
jr are asking the department of justice
to intervene after a north carolina
district attorney so the deputies would
not be charged in connection to his
fatal shooting
the attorney said in a statement on
tuesday we certainly got neither
transparency nor justice today
we request that the federal department
of justice intervene immediately
district attorney andrew wamble
announced tuesday that deputies who
fatally shot brown last month were
justified in using deadly force a
finding that the attorney described as
an insult and a slap in the face
womble also played four body camera
videos to the public for the first time
on tuesday
brown's family and community have called
for a public full public release of the
videos since his death on april 21st
and now they've gotten it it's been
released um the three deputies who fired
at brown at 42 year old black men while
attempting to serve warrants will also
be reinstated and retrained
uh wooten said
however he said disciplinary action
would be taken against the deputies who
responded to the scene
quote while the district attorney
concluded that no criminal law was
violated this was a terrible and tragic
outcome and we could do better
that doesn't really make a lot of sense
to me
if you're saying that no law was
violated they didn't do anything wrong
then
i i understand he's trying to thread the
needle here
and make a compromise and give a little
bit to both to both sides there's no
point in doing that
because either
you arrest all of the officers and
charge them with murder
and then convict them
or
anything short of that is not going to
be satisfying to blm
so if you're not going to do that then
you might as well
there's no point in um
throwing them any kind of bone at all
because it's not going to make a
difference
and in this case it's it's pretty clear
he gets into his car you drive a group
of officers
and he gets shot
that's something that you do
you know and this is something that i've
brought up before but uh
it isn't discussed very often
but it's worth
thinking about talking about
if we could just for a second
get away from analyzing the behavior of
the police officers
there's more than enough of that
we've done we've done a lot of that of
talking about how the police officers
respond
but what about getting inside the head
of somebody like andrew brown
why would you do that
you're you are a criminal they're coming
to arrest you you're committing crimes
fair is fair okay
um
and you've got there are i don't know
five six seven i'm not sure how many
police officers there but but a whole
group of police officers heavily armed
and they're rolling up in their vans
they're out there they got their guns
drawn
and you get in your car and you try to
drive away what what do you think is
going to happen what's the best case
scenario in your mind how do you think
this is going to play out
you you must know if you are at all a
sane individual you must know that the
moment you make that decision your
chances of dying have just increased 100
fold
if you had stopped right there and got
down on the ground put your hands up and
did everything they said your chances of
dying are basically non-existent if you
follow all their instructions
um
you start to resist and then the chances
go up you do something like get into the
car and drive towards a group of them
even if you didn't mean to hit them
which of course as far as they're
concerned like they're not going to know
your intentions you're driving a car
towards them
they have a right to assume that you're
trying to hit them and you're a deadly
threat and they're going to treat you
that way
but even if you didn't mean to
even if that wasn't your intention
you must know that your chances of
getting shot and killed have gone up
dramatically
and if you're not shot and killed well
what then
so you get into a high speed chase uh
the police show up the helicopter comes
you're not gonna escape the helicopter
you're not going to get away
unless you're a a secret cia agent or
something you've got the whole plan
ready to go you've got your go bag
you've got your your passports new
identity
and even then i'm not sure you're
getting away
but this is an action movie and you're
an action hero and you've got the whole
plan in place maybe you do but short of
that
you're not going to get away all you're
doing now is
at best
increasing your coming prison sentence
significantly
and yet that's the choice that andrew
brown made it's the same choice that
dante wright made
most of the the blm martyrs it's the
choice that they made so i think our
question should be why don't they value
their own lives
this is not about
police officers
understanding that black lives matter
police officers know that
everyone knows that
but andrew brown didn't seem to think
that his own life mattered
so maybe we should be talking about that
dante wright didn't seem to value his
own life
he was willing to throw it away for
nothing
to throw it away in exchange for nothing
gaining nothing from it
we should be talking but we can't talk
about that because all we do is talk
about the police officers
all right number two this is from fox
news it says a ten-year-old boy a
florida boy slammed his local school
board during a public meeting last week
calling the district's mask mandate
unfair to kids during an emergency
session on reopening guidelines
the boy later identified as john begins
by describing himself as a student at
felix a williams elementary school in
martin county
um and we'll play the some of his
remarks in just a second but
not to get not the spoiler alert here
not to spoil the ending but following
his remarks the board voted four to one
to keep masks mandatory for the
remaining days of the current school
year
in spite of what he had to say the kids
pleading with them can we take the masks
off there's no reason for us to have the
masks on to begin with uh they they
elected to keep the masks on anyway but
i thought uh this kid i mean he's 10
years old
and uh this is
pretty eloquent
for anyone of any age let alone a 10
year old let's uh let's listen
i expected school to be a little bit
different in the beginning
but i didn't think it would stay this
way all year long
and i was surprised by the rules
a lot of them didn't make any sense to
me like the fact that we were not
allowed to play on the playground or
have stupid counsel
or
turn to face each other at lunch and we
also have to wear masks outside at pe
and on
track i love my school now but my
teachers seem really stressed and that
makes me feel bad
one teacher walks around with a
clipboard full of referrals for any
student whose mask isn't on properly it
makes me feel scared
that same teacher yells at us having our
mess down to drink water while we are
outside in caroline she told us we had
to wait until we were in our parents car
to have a drink of water she had her
mask down the entire time while she was
yelling at us which makes me and all my
friends very mad
my mask also sticks to my face when it's
really hot and it makes it hard to
breathe
i feel like i can't catch my breath and
that makes me feel claustrophobic and
anxious it's really stressful
i finished taking all of my fsas and i
had a hard time focusing with a mask on
a few weeks ago i ran into my teacher
outside of school she didn't even
recognize me
because she's never seen my face before
that that is that last part there is
just sad uh it's also sad that this is a
ten-year-old boy making a far more
compelling argument against wearing
masks than any adult on the other side
of the issue has made in favor of of
children wearing the masks
because they've never made any argument
at all really it's it's it's their own
fear and uh
and disregard for the kids that's all it
is there's never really any argument
presented
and he that was longer than that he went
on for two and a half three minutes um
again 10 year old boy laying out the
case this is why we don't we should be
wearing the masks trying to explain it
to adults
four or five times his age
makes no difference they keep the masks
in place any anyway
i was reading some of the some of the
responses online to this and of course
there were people
saying
oh he he didn't write that this is
parents this is mom wrote it and is
using him
as a prop
i think that's really ironic because i
guarantee you
that
most of the people making that claim
about that kid that he's being used he
didn't really write it this isn't his
choice uh most of those people are the
exact same people who if that
ten-year-old boy was identifying as a
girl they'd be applauding it if that
ten-year-old boy was dressed up as a
drag queen they'd be applauding it
now in that case it's not about the
parents making the decision the parents
using the child but here
they have it exactly backwards of course
because normally
i don't like it when kids are used to
make statements
um
political statements
statements of any kind really i think
kids should just be kids
this is different
for a really obvious reason
he is the one directly affected
okay this is not so often what you get
you get this especially from the left
the parents have their own political and
ideological priorities that have nothing
to do with the kids and they use the kid
as a mouthpiece or a mascot for their
own priorities
it's not helping the kid at all in this
case though the kids are the ones
affected
they are very much caught up in this
and we haven't really heard from the
kids at all they don't have a voice
it's it's been all the adults arguing
about it
and then finally a kid gets up there and
speaks for himself
and you have a bunch of adults
shut up kid
let the adults let the adults talk about
whether you should be muzzled for the
rest of the school year for no reason
i'm sure his mother i'm sure his parents
probably did help him come up with that
good for them
you know what they're doing they're
teaching the their son
to stand up for himself
to speak up for himself
that's an important
ability for a person to have for a child
to develop
so well well done to uh to the child and
the parents but not so much the members
of the school board
i can't believe that they they i mean of
course you can believe it but
they said too bad they had no response
to the kid but too bad wear the mask
anyway
all right moving now reading from raw
story which is a leftist rag online rag
it says jacob chansley dubbed the q anon
shaman in the media is among the most
famous of the capital rioters who is
facing federal criminal charges in
connection with the january 6
insurrection albert watkins chan
chansley's
attorney discussed his clients with
talking points memo talking point memos
matt shuham which talking point points
memo is another leftist rag
um
anyway
so talking points memo has this quote
from matt shuham
or rather matt shuham is talking voice
memo albert watkins is the attorney okay
i'm all kinds of confused
um
has a quote from
the lawyer
again this is
q anon shaman's lawyer supposed to be
representing him
in this federal case
and this is what his lawyer says about
him
this is the quote
as much of it as as i can read anyway
he says a lot of these defendants and
i'm going to use the colloquial term
perhaps disrespectfully
but they're all effing short bus people
these are people with brain damage
they're effing [ __ ] they're on the
damn spectrum
but they're our brothers our sisters our
neighbors our coworkers they're part of
our country these aren't bad people they
don't have uh prior criminal history
they were subjected to four plus years
of damn propaganda the likes of which
the world has not seen since effing
hitler
okay that is the lawyer
for jacob chansley the quote-unquote q
anon shaman his lawyer saying that about
him
that he's quote effing [ __ ] and is a
short bus person
um
leaving aside the demeaning and
degrading language uh to to people with
learning disabilities and so on
this if you want to understand
why a lot of these people that were
involved in the capital riot uh why some
of them are still languishing in prison
getting hunted down
having these being charged with uh
crimes that could carry 20 years in
prison
clearly
way beyond what is what is justified
according to the law
and uh it this helps clarify it a little
bit because this is
you know this is the kind of caliber of
lawyer they're able to get to represent
them
they have the entire system against them
so much so that even their lawyer
is against them
it does make me wonder um
speaking of of these people
where is where is trump on
this why isn't he speaking on their
behalf
these are his supporters that are being
hunted down like dogs
and thrown in cages
the federal government wants to wants to
pin decades on them in prison
for trespassing
and doing that while
blm rioters people who burned down
police stations
burned down convenience stores assaulted
police officers
most of them have never even been
arrested they're just out there
some of them are still out in the street
you have you know antifa anarchists
waging an assault on a federal
courthouse
for months
many of them never even arrested for it
not once arrested
while in this case the entire force of
the federal government is coming down
there's no question this is politically
motivated no doubt about it's a
political witch hunt there's no doubt
and it's outrageous it's unjust
especially when you compare it to the to
the non-response
uh to the blm writers and so i i am
wondering what
why trump isn't speaking up on their
behalf a little bit more
has he said anything
have you said anything it hasn't been
much
all right this is from
okay this is from the daily i'm i'm
regretting i'm about to read this
because it's such an upsetting and
horrible story but i'll read it anyway
it's from the daily wire it says an 18
year old an 18 year old snatched a
sleeping four-year-old boy from his
dallas home early saturday morning
and brutally beat him to death leaving
his lifeless bloodied body in a street
court documents and video surveillance
reportedly show
the child identified monday as kash
gurnen was living with his biological
father's former girlfriend cash and his
twin brother were left in the woman's
care after their father disappeared in
march the boy's biological mother says
she doesn't did not know her twins were
in the care of her former of the former
girlfriend and had been searching for
her boys she is now with cash's twin
darren brown 18 has been arrested and
charged with kidnapping and burglary
more charges are expected as forensic is
reviewed the alleged killer's bond is
set at 1.5 million
um
the daily mail reported that brown was
wearing an ankle monitor when he was
detained
so he's wearing an ankle monitor he
breaks into the house kidnaps this kid
and
brutalizes him and kills him and leaves
him
bloody on the ground dead
this is a four-year-old
i'm searching for things i can say about
this that won't get me in a lot of
trouble
all i will say
and we'll leave it at this this is why
we need the death penalty for cases like
this
public a public execution i think would
be really appropriate in a case like
this
but certainly at least an execution of
some kind
this is in cases like this this is what
put me over the edge to being pro death
penalty after being against it for a
while
but there are some crimes that
are beyond imagining
you you can't even you can't wrap your
head around them
they're so horrific
that when a person does it
there is no other response from a
civilized society but to
rid society of that person permanently
what would be the anyone who's against
capital punishment what
what would be the better approach
so we take darren brown he's 18.
you put him in prison and you're going
to need to put him in protective custody
for his entire life
of course the other option is to put him
in general population and tell the
prison guards to just get a little
distracted for a few moments
and look the other way and let the
prison population do what it's going to
do i'd be fine with that too but
assuming you're not going to do that so
you're going to put them in
in
protective custody which is more
expensive for the taxpayer
for the rest of his life he's 18 he's
going to let's say he lives until he's
you know he could live another easily
another 60 years or more
six decades
of
taxpayers not only feeding and housing
this guy but paying extra to protect him
and for what
for what purpose what what do we gain
from that
what does he gain from
that this isn't about rehabilitating him
to send him out back out in society he's
never going to be out in society ever
again
so it's not that
is it about redemption is it about him
uh you know coming to confront the his
his own heinous crimes
that that can happen with the death
penalty too in fact i think the death
penalty facilitates that
when you know when there's a date set
and you know that you're going to die on
this day
it certainly gives you a chance
um
to
confront your own sins
so i just don't see i don't see the
point i don't see the argument for
keeping someone like that alive
for six decades in prison
just for them to die naturally anyway
i don't see it
all right finally this is from the new
york post
in a measure that will likely irk flyers
airlines could soon require plus-sized
passengers to step on the scale or
provide their weight before boarding the
aircraft
the initiative which was outlined in a
recent federal aviation administration
advisory strikes to provide strives to
provide new data on average passenger
weights as the current numbers
reportedly don't reflect today's
sky-high obesity rates
and in turn this would help ensure
aircrafts especially the small ones
don't exceed their allowable weight
limit so this is a little disturbing it
is what we're being told is that um
there's the standard weight limit for
airplanes but that was all calculated
before americans got really fat and so
now it has to be recalibrated we need to
figure out just how fat everyone is
before they get on a flight and so
that's why people need to need to get
weighed
all i ask this is the only thing i'm
asking is that the weights be announced
on the intercom
we could do like a public weigh-in
before the flight
or else maybe each passenger as they
board their weight could be announced
almost like a boxer coming coming to the
ring
all right boarding now it's mrs shelby
johnson weighing in at 195 pounds
something like that i don't know and
then the good thing is if when everyone
gets on the on the flight if you realize
that you're a little bit overweight
then the captain could come over the
intercom and say okay ladies ladies and
gentlemen we're we're currently 267
pounds overweight
fortunately that means we only need to
lose one passenger
passenger in 12a you're gonna have to
leave you know it makes it easier all
i'm saying is that the flying experience
is already degrading and dehumanizing
so we might as well go all in
and it'd be a great incentive to lose
weight also
um all right let's move now to reading
the youtube comments this is from robert
mcgregor says three of my favorite thing
things shrimp to eat the matt wall show
and marvel's avengers dude you're
tearing me apart
well robert you have to you have to
choose
he can't have us all
i'm drawing a line right here
it's me or the shrimp and and the
avengers
choose wisely
autumn says my orthodontist office is
still making me wear a mask
even though i'm fully vaccinated they
told me that they have to wait until the
board of dentistry says that they can
change policy your orthodontist
is telling you to wear a mask you have
to wear the mask when they're doing
when they're working on your teeth i
wonder how that works or no because we
know that's not it you have to wear a
mask in the waiting room and when you're
walking into
um
you know the room with the chair but
then you take the mask off and they have
they have their their hands in your
mouth
makes a lot of sense
um justin pirro says at least some good
has come of all this mayor lightfoot is
going to keep that mug covered for us
and i can't thank her enough for it well
listen
that's very rude but i also say
you know maybe that is one advantage of
the people who are perpetually masking
maybe we can assume that they're all
ugly and they're trying to hide their
shame
so really if you see someone still
masking at this point because i believe
in empathy and everything
um and i'm very compassionate persons i
i think you could
you know assume that they're wearing it
because they're ugly and just walk up to
them and say listen um
it's okay to be hideous you don't have
to be ashamed
take that mask off i i think they'd
really appreciate that
finally bill zusner says i wonder if
matt knows that being a contrarian
doesn't make him better
well bill i i totally disagree
i want to take a second to tell you
about helix sleep uh you know i've been
telling you about helix for
for months now uh or or well over a year
now
and uh we're such big fans of helix
sleep in my house that we now have two
helix mattresses we've got one my wife
and i have a helix mattress my daughter
has a helix mattress the boys don't have
helix mattresses yet they'll be fine
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you i've been
through this process a couple of times
now and it's very very easy to find the
perfect mattress if you like a mattress
that's really soft or firm if you sleep
on your side or your back or your
stomach or you sleep really hot whatever
it is with helix there's a specific
mattress for each and everybody's unique
taste you don't need to take their word
for it helix was awarded the number one
best overall mattress of 2019 and 2020
by gq and wired magazine and also i have
awarded them the number one mattress so
i think that's the most important thing
just go to helixsleep.comwalsh take
their two minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life you got to do this and actually
sleep well at night for a change right
now helix is offering up to 200 off and
free pillows with all mattress orders
for our listeners at helix sleep dot com
slash walsh that's helix sleep.com walsh
for up to 200 off your mattress order
and if you're interested in winning a
trip to the daily wire headquarters uh
to walk in the same halls
as yours truly
not exactly the same halls but you know
in the vicinity of the same halls now's
your chance you are not going to meet me
but you will meet candace owens if you
sign up as a daily wire member with code
vip you'll get twenty percent off your
new membership and be automatically
entered for a chance to win a trip to
the daily wire studios to see candace
live not only will we meet will you be
meeting candace you'll be getting an
inside look at her studio our office and
front row seats to watch her live and in
action on our talk show candace so don't
wait go enter to win a candace vip pass
now at dailywire.com
subscribe using code vip for 20 off and
for an experience that only joe biden
will forget i got to stop using that
joke at the end i think i think we get
we get the joke at the end are you guys
still laughing at that joke anyway now
let's get to our daily cancellation
so today we have the great
privilege of once again canceling chris
cuomo um so after the supreme court
announced on monday that it would be it
would uh rule on mississippi's law
banning abortion after 15 weeks
potentially putting roe v wade on the
chopping block the left in the media
have been trying desperately to explain
why we must not infringe on a mother's
god-given right to have her children
dismembered
they've not done a very good job of
making this case though um and although
i should say in fairness to them it's
not really possible to make a good case
for such a hideously depraved thing
cnn anchor chris cuomo
continuing his lifelong contest with his
brother andrew to see who can be the
biggest embarrassment in the family
demonstrated this difficulty during a
monologue on a show a couple of nights
ago cuomo spent two minutes laying out
his argument in defense of roe and the
end result is a muddled indecipherable
mess of half-baked talking points and ad
hominem attacks
it was exactly the sort of thing we so
often hear from people on his side of
the issue
which is why it might be worth
dissecting in some detail so we're going
to take this piece by piece
and watch his monologue and and i'll
respond to it let's start here
all right here is a bolo be on the
lookout we are about to see if mitch
mcconnell's supreme court mission pays
off
it's now a six to three decidedly
conservative court
and it now says the supreme court of the
united states that it will hear a case
that could remove a woman's right to
control her own body
remove a woman's right to control her
own body
that might be a fair characterization if
mississippi was mandating that women
have chips installed in their brains
that would enable the governor to steer
them around like remote-controlled cars
but that's not the law at issue here as
far as i know no such law has been
proposed anywhere and if any law is
proposed like that i will oppose it
the issue here is whether women have the
right to destroy someone else's body
yes the other body is dependent on their
own body for survival but does it does a
body's dependence on your own
give you the moral and legal right to
exterminate it
even if that other body is your own
child do you have that right
and if you say that a mother has the
right to destroy any body dependent on
her own for survival then as we talked
about yesterday you must explain why
that logic should not also apply outside
of the womb as much as it applies inside
it
born children are just as dependent and
helpless especially at their youngest
ages why shouldn't their dependence also
negate their right to exist
or perhaps you think it should
however you sort through all of this
we should be clear that this is the
question
it is a question about a woman's rights
over another human's body
it is not a question about her rights
over her own body
just to be clear
let's continue
dobbs v jackson mississippi women's
health organization
it tests a state law that bans almost
all efforts to end a pregnancy after 15
weeks including pregnancies resulting
from incest or rape
legally
the issue is fetal viability
when does what is inside a woman become
a person with rights under the law
you would think we would have empaneled
experts on a special commission by now
to see what the science says right but
we don't seem to have the intellectual
curiosity about this issue because it's
not really about science
it has become a culture war it's a
political lever to use as a distraction
from policy and solving problems to
allow people to get up in their religion
and their righteousness over any sense
of what science suggests
cuomo says that abortion has become
a culture war issue apparently under the
oppression that there was a time when it
was not a cultural worship even more
absurd
he pegs pro-lifers as the ones who shy
away from the personhood debate
what he doesn't realize or pretends not
to realize is that we build our whole
case around personhood we advocate for
personhood amendments and personhood
laws we want nothing more than to talk
about personhood
though we don't want to leave the issue
up to a panel of experts
we've seen what a mess self-appointed
experts can make of things and i'm not
quite sure who the experts on personhood
would be anyway
cuomo believes that the scientists can
settle it
but all the scientists can tell us is
that a person is a human being
if you wish to draw some distinction
between human being and person
then you are making a legal and moral
case not a scientific one
you're also attempting the same trick
that advocates of slavery pulled the
same trick that has served as the
foundation and justification for many of
the world's greatest atrocities and
genocides throughout history history
proves that nothing good ever happens
when you attempt to draw a dividing line
between human and person
that is one of the reasons why
pro-lifers are happy to stick with a
scientific answer on this question a
person is a human being plain and simple
anyone claiming otherwise has the burden
of proof entirely on their own shoulders
but the pro-abortion side has never
tried to meet that burden
they tell us that an unborn human isn't
a person
and yet they won't tell us what a person
actually is
they're the ones who don't want to talk
about personhood
they'd be even less interested in
commissioning a panel of experts
than even we are
do you think planned parenthood would
welcome an expert commission panel
to figure out when personhood begins
you think planned parenthood would want
that to happen you think naral would
want that to happen
so cuomo has this part of the issue
completely backwards and he has every
other part backwards too of course let's
keep watching
though medical capabilities may be
moving the point of viability well short
of what it was assumed to be in 1973
with roe v wade so you'd think some of
the proponents
of harsher measures would want the
science involved
most americans
want the court to uphold roe v wade
which found women have liberty over
their own body as a right to privacy a
privacy right under the 14th amendment
62 uphold 24 overturned but again it's
not about science or consensus it's
about dividing lines
what he calls for a scientific
discussion and then as then as if as if
it counts as scientific evidence he
appeals to an abc news survey
what does that have to do with anything
who cares what the public thinks
he directly conflates the two or at
least puts them on equal footing by
talking about science or consensus
he's not even referring to a consensus
of scientists here but a narrow and
limited consensus of random people who
took an abc news poll
what the hell do i care about what is
that what does that matter at all
what scientific weight does that have
if we're trying to figure out whether an
unborn human is a person what you want
to decide it based on abc news surveys
so things have gone fully off of the
logical rails here now it's time for the
real train wreck to begin
legislating to the far right white
fright vote
flooding the zone with 536 bills that
abridge a woman's right to control her
own body in 46 states
it's just like voting rights in one way
you see
it seems like the far right only cares
about protecting humans before they are
born
sure why not throw it all in i mean the
racist label the voting rights talking
point the thing about pro-lifers only
caring about people before they're born
put it all in the blender like a
rhetorical smoothie you might as well
never mind that the voting rights issue
has nothing to do with anything never
mind that that pro-life racism is so
bizarrely self-sabotaging black babies
are killed disproportionately by
abortion
the end of abortion would mean a
dramatic increase in the black
population
that is one strange racist conspiracy
you have to admit
or perhaps it's not a racist conspiracy
at all
as for the claim that pro-lifers only
care about people before they're born
which is a boring and repetitive talking
point we hear all the time even if that
were true it would still be preferable
to the total disregard for human life so
often displayed by chris cuomo and his
ideological compatriots but it's not
true of course
it doesn't make any sense
the whole reason why pro-lifers care
about the unborn
is that we draw no moral distinction
between them and born
that's our argument
if we thought that born humans had no
value as chris cuomo suggests
then we'd feel the same about the unborn
our entire position is based on the
premise that human life has inherent
value inherent means you can't gain it
or lose it
you have it always
if we didn't believe that
if we didn't care about human life
then we wouldn't be pro-life
this should be obvious unless you really
have convinced yourself that the
pro-life movement is nothing but a
handmaid's tale plot to enslave women
another quite odd plot we have to
say given that so many pro-lifers are
themselves women
i mean go to the march for life sometime
go to a fundraising banquet for a
pregnancy resource center go stand a
vigil at an abortion clinic you're going
to find a majority of women in all of
those places almost every time
it would seem that this is not a plot to
control women's bodies after all it
would seem that we pro-lifers just
really do oppose the murder of
defenseless and innocent human beings
who would have thought
who could have imagined
well cuomo didn't think
and he doesn't think in general
but unfortunately that doesn't stop him
from talking
and for that reason today
he is canceled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pavel vadasky the show is edited
by sasha tolmachov our audio is mixed by
mike coromina hair makeup is done by
nikka geneva and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matte
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show public health pseudo
experts and their political allies are
unmasked as the real science deniers the
andrew brown case comes apart and the
radical left's mask comes off when it
comes to winking and anti-semitism
that's today on the bench bureau show
give it a listen